así es muy buenas tardes pues olaf
scholz cumplió como manda digamos la
tradición que es una vez pues haya sido
nombrado el canciller alemán su primera
visita de estado la realiza a parís
ambos mandatarios en realizaron
brevemente tuvieron un almuerzo de
trabajo y luego dieron unas breves
declaraciones también a la prensa
declaraciones en las que dijeron que
habían ha tocado gran parte de los temas
más importantes de la relación entre
ambos países y también pues los temas
digamos más candentes a nivel europeo en
cuanto a las preguntas de la prensa por
supuesto les preguntaron sobre la
situación de entre en la frontera entre
ucrania y rusia y ambos mandatarios pese
a explicaros que explicaron que ellos
por supuesto van a estar siempre del
lado de sus aliados en este caso de
ucrania por el respeto también de las
fronteras europeas y que están
dispuestos a continuar trabajando para
que se puedan apaciguar las tensiones en
esta región siguiendo el formato de
normandía ese formato que fue creado en
2014 y en el que tanto francia como
alemania pues funcionan como mediadores
entre rusia
a ambos
ambos mandatarios también se dijeron que
saludaban y que felicitaban también las
iniciativas de joe biden el presidente
de eeuu quien esta semana también pues
se habló con el presidente putin al
respecto de lo que está sucediendo en
esa en ese lugar y también pues se les
preguntó acerca de ese boicot que se
está pues del boicot a los juegos
olímpicos en beijing de boicot
diplomático por ahora ambos dijeron que
lo que quieren es una respuesta
concertada no solamente estos dos países
sino a nivel europeo aunque de manuel ma
como calificó esto de digamos que era un
boicot o pequeño pero sobre todo
simbólico y por último pues ya se les
habló si en algún momento se podría
pensar en una respuesta digamos
uniforme a nivel europeo en cuanto a la
crisis sanitaria demás sobre todo
digamos en cuanto a las diferentes
medidas o por ejemplo como los pases
sanitarios y demás por ahora ellos
dijeron que se ha tratado de trabajar de
manera
cooperada de manera pues conjunta entre
todos los
países pero no dijeron nada digamos de
que hubiera una son las reglas para todo
el bloque